comment ne pas parler des pixels 7 et
comment ne pas parler des pixels 7 Pro
regardez j'ai les trois boîtes là alors
aujourd'hui on va venir se parler des
pixels 7 Pro on se parlera probablement
un peu plus tard des pixels 7 et on se
parlera avec certitude de cette montre
là aussi bientôt c'est la Google pixel
watch c'est la première fois que Google
arrive avec une montre connectée avec
Fitbit bon ça c'est pas pour aujourd'hui
ça c'est pour la prochaine fois
aujourd'hui on va se concentrer non pas
sur les pixels mais sur les pixels 7 Pro
pourquoi et bien parce que alors c'est
une très jolie évolution par rapport au
pixel 6 pro qu'on avait vu l'année
dernière que je vous avais déjà présenté
on va regarder un peu ce que ça raconte
ce que ça montre qu'apporte ce nouveau
processeur le Google tenseur G2 la
deuxième génération du processeur de
Google qui travaille assez différemment
des processeurs de Qualcomm en tout cas
c'est l'idée derrière que nous raconte
Google donc on va regarder tout ça mais
on va le faire quand et bien juste après
le générique allez on y va
[Musique]
avoir un beau smartphone c'est bien mais
pensez à venir le protéger avec les
coques de mon partenaire rhinoshield et
avec le code gros 23 profité de -5% sur
l'ensemble de vos achats sur le site de
rhinoshield et rhinoshield va lancer
très bientôt des coques pour les pixels
pixel 7 pro je vous invite à venir vous
inscrire via le lien en bas dans la
description pour être tenu informé dès
que c'est quand arriveront et bien
évidemment pour venir faire tous vos
achats sur le site de rhinoshield comme
d'habitude avec rhinoshield vous avez
des tonnes de collaboration super
intéressantes regardez ici c'est Dragon
Ball Z coque super hyper canon si vous
voulez le dragon vous pouvez l'avoir
également comme ça mais on a aussi Game
of Thrones si vous voulez avoir le trône
de fer au dos de votre Smartphone vous
pouvez la voir Marvel bien évidemment
Docteur Strange personnellement celle là
je l'adore et vous avez des coques dans
plein d'univers différents One Piece et
compagnie il y a énormément de
collaboration sur le site de rhinoshield
Star Wars avec le Faucon Millenium et
plein d'autres produits à découvrir
directement sur le site de rhinoshield
que ce soit des grips qui sont
compatibles ici directement avec vos
pixels sur l'île suit bien évidemment
des protections d'écran peuvent venir
les personnaliser on a des accessoires
des câbles bref il y en a pour tout le
monde même des protections pour vos
objectifs ces produits vont être
disponibles pour les pixels six pixel 7
pro mais également pour les pixels 6
pixel 6 pro sans oublier les pixel 5
venez jeter un coup d'oeil sur le site
de rhinoshield je vous mets le lien une
fois de plus en bas dans la description
et n'oubliez pas avec le code gros 23
vous avez 5 % de remise sur l'ensemble
du site et ça c'est chouette et merci à
rhinoshi d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
alors regardez là vous voyez les boîtes
c'est bien joli mais moi j'ai les
produits à vous montrer directement on
l'a dans trois finitions différentes je
sais pas lequel vous préférez en fait ce
sont tous les trois des deux brillants
donc si vous aimez les deux brillons et
bien vous aurez un truc qui fera
l'affaire si vous n'aimez pas les deux
brillants et bien c'est peut-être pas
trop fait pour vous il y a un côté un
peu bling bling sur celui-là sur cette
petite couleur c'est le verso je alors
personnellement je trouve ça marrant ça
change un petit peu donc j'aime bien ce
qu'on voit si vous regardez bien là et
bien c'est que ça prend quand même pas
mal les petites traces de doigts les
petites marques vous voyez il y en a un
peu de tous les côtés donc si vous êtes
extrêmement maniaque ça peut un peu
venir vous agacer à côté de ça on a ce
dos ici en vert que c'est sympa alors
j'avais cassé moi c'est sur le pixel 6
pour l'année dernière j'avais cassé un
bord là donc une fois de plus ici venez
vraiment les protéger pour éviter les
déconvenues vous avez ce modèle noir qui
sera le plus sobre probablement le plus
passe partout qui est aussi très élégant
vous avez le modèle blanc qui est assez
sympa comme ça aussi que j'aime beaucoup
et puis vous avez ce petit Verseau qui
change un petit peu alors on va se
concentrer sur celui-là pour l'instant
déjà le premier truc c'est la question
du design est-ce que vous aimez dites le
moi dans les commentaires est-ce que
vous aimez ce petit module photo voyez
qui vient légèrement dépasser ici alors
il apporte une certaine instabilité si
on vient vraiment appuyer sur le dessus
après me direz-vous pourquoi est-ce que
je voudrais appuyer sur le dessus
globalement il est assez peu de raison
il est très changeant par rapport au
reste du marché par rapport à ce qu'on
retrouve donc globalement je dois
reconnaître que j'aime beaucoup le fait
qu'on ait des choses qui soient
différentes par rapport aux autres
smartphones vous avez uniquement le bloc
photo ici donc ça ça change et ça c'est
plutôt pas mal ça c'est juste une
question de goût de couleur est-ce que
vous allez aimer ça oui non quoi comment
j'aime bien le petit logo j'ai du Google
qui est très discret là on a
effectivement toute la partie norme
européenne qui est planqué ici qui est
presque ton sur ton donc qui est aussi
très très élégant et ça ça marche ça se
voit légèrement plus sur le modèle blanc
versus le modèle noir alors faut
vraiment le chercher ici sur le noir
c'est pareil c'est extrêmement discret
donc on voit que dans point de vue
design après on est on n'aime pas en
tout cas ça reste très cohérent ça
fonctionne donc ça ça me va bien autre
élément effectivement et bien c'est un
très grand écran qu'on va retrouver vous
voyez déjà le truc qui est intéressant
c'est que moi j'ai activé le
déverrouillé cette reconnaissance de mon
visage et lorsque il va ma tronche et
bien vous voyez il fait un petit rond là
sur le côté là ça ça veut dire qu'il m'a
vu et qui va pouvoir venir déverrouiller
donc il déverrouille très facilement si
vous ne voulez pas venir déverrouiller
comme ça et bien vous avez également le
capteur d'empreintes digitale vous posez
votre doigt et ça déverrouille très bien
donc ça c'est plutôt cool autre élément
ici à venir prendre en compte c'est le
fait que l'écran est incurvé tout le
monde n'aime pas les écrans incurvés moi
j'aime bien ce petit écran incurvé là je
trouve ça sympa ça porte de la
profondeur donc si vous aimez les écrans
incurvés ici aussi il y a pas de
problème ça fonctionnera bien cet écran
je l'aime bien je trouve bien je trouve
clair je trouve lumineux je trouve
agréable à venir regarder vous allez
soit avoir des couleurs adaptatives
c'est coché par défaut soit des couleurs
naturelles personnellement j'aime bien
l'adaptatif où c'est un petit peu plus
flatteur au niveau de l'écran du
smartphone la résolution qui est
également mis en Full HD plus par défaut
que vous pouvez monter en qHD plus
attention si vous augmenter la
résolution de l'écran vous allez venir
consommer davantage au niveau de votre
batterie avez-vous besoin d'une
résolution au qHD plus je suis pas
forcément convaincu c'est à vous de voir
si vous voulez vraiment le meilleur
d'expérience et bien vous pouvez rester
ici en cuillage des plus et puis le
dernier point c'est ce qu'ils
appelleront ici l'affichage fluide c'est
votre taux de rafraîchissement en fait
vous venez activer ici vous allez monter
jusqu'en 100 verre et après ça va être
géré automatiquement puisqu'ici vous
avez une dalle ltpo donc dalle de bonne
qualité je l'aime bien je la trouve très
très efficace elle marche bien et pour
venir visionner des films des séries
tout ce que vous voulez il y aura
absolument aucune mauvaise surprise et
après il y a un autre truc qui est
vachement intéressant à voir c'est
l'audio alors attendez je mets la pause
vous avez deux haut-parleurs
haut-parleurs ici qui situe juste sur ce
côté là et puis tu haut parleur c'est le
palourde renfort alors pour autant vous
allez voir que le haut-parleur de
renfort c'est pas ouf hein il fait un
peu coin coin l'eau par leur principal
par contre il envoie du bois mais il
envoie vraiment bien du bois
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous le tout ça fonce assez
médium et c'est très très fort vous
voyez et si je la bouche lui
il y a plus grand chose alors évitez de
façon de le pousser à fond d'une parce
que c'est vraiment très fort et ça ne
sert à rien et puis deuxièmement il va
me dire quand même légèrement saturé
néanmoins je dois reconnaître que
l'expérience est pas mauvaise ce que je
vous recommande quand même c'est de
venir utiliser ici des écouteurs des
bugs pour vos appels mais également pour
profiter de la meilleure expérience
multimédia maintenant ce qui est
vraiment le plus intéressant ici et ce
qui va être le plus pertinent et bien
c'est cette nouvelle puce c'est la puce
de Google c'est la Google tensor G2
c'est la deuxième génération alors
souvenez-vous on vient en 2021 Google
sortait pour la première fois ça pusse
pour son smartphone alors j'en parle
avec Google et ils me disent en fait non
l'idée de la Google tensor c'est pas
d'être la plus la plus performante par
rapport à ce qu'on peut faire par
rapport à de la performance brute comme
on aura sur un Qualcomm stand dragon 8
plus Jen one c'est pas l'idée l'idée ici
c'est d'avoir une puce qui est optimisée
pour ce que c'est faire Google pour les
services Google pour tout ce que va
proposer Google ici parce que l'idée une
fois de plus c'est la sécurité c'est le
fait que tout se passe en interne dans
votre smartphone alors on connaît Google
on connaît la puissance de calcul de
Google on connaît les algorithmes de
Google mais l'idée c'est que cette puce
elle fasse le boulot directement ici
dans smartphone pour garder le maximum
d'informations ici en plus de ça les
corrélés avec la plus de sécurité la
Titan m2 donc en termes de sécurité on a
ce qui va bien je vous l'ai déjà dit
lorsque je voulais présenter anti
fishing anti malware et puis un VPN qui
va arriver bientôt et Google one donc ça
c'est plutôt cool maintenant le truc qui
va venir m'intéresser c'est de me dire
ok on a une nouvelle puce ok on a des
fonctionnalités dédiées à Google quels
sont-elles qu'est-ce que je peux me
faire avec ce smartphone que je ne
viendrai pas faire avec d'autres alors
il y a deux choses à venir différencier
ici il y a ce qu'on va appeler les
fonctionnalités pixel first c'est à dire
des fonctionnalités qu'on aura d'abord
sur votre pixel et après sur d'autres
smartphone Android et puis vous aurez
ensuite les fonctionnalités qu'on
appellera pixel only ce sont des
fonctionnalités que vous n'aurez que
dans votre pixel parce que seul votre
pixel sera le faire grâce à cette puce
Google tensor G2 donc c'est vraiment
l'intérêt de cette puce c'est d'avoir
des fonctionnalités dédiées qu'on le
retrouvera pas ailleurs pour avoir une
vraie expérience 100% Google et moi il y
a ceux qui m'ont vraiment bluffé le truc
qui m'a bluffé tout de suite regardez
c'est pour venir hop là je vous mets une
photo de moi là je suis enfin j'ai quoi
là j'ai 20 20 et quelques balais et bien
il y a une fonctionnalité pour enlever
le côté un peu légèrement flou de la
photo vous voyez elle est floue cette
photo là et en fait le truc est dingue
je viens d'en vérifier et là il vient me
proposer juste ici l'anti flou alors je
me mets comme ça j'appuie sur anti flou
je zoom un peu ma tronche et c'est
absolument dingue je trouve ça mais
complètement dingue regardez là je peux
remettre le flou et j'enlève le flou
donc là c'est la photo qui était modifié
par l'algo regardez lorsque j'appuie
j'ai le flou qui revient et ce truc là
c'est dingue parce que en fait il y a
coté un peu perturbant parce que ça
c'est une photo je vous dis à plus de 20
ans cette photo on me voit j'ai plus la
même couleur de cheveux j'ai quand même
des choses qui sont passées le temps a
fait son œuvre la boucle d'oreille est
partie pas toute seule mais c'est moi
qui l'ai enlevé et voyez ça me fait
vraiment voyager dans le temps et je
trouve ça très cool et à la fois un côté
un peu un peu déstabilisant maintenant
sur la monter encore plus loin dans le
passé ça c'est moi et je suis très jeune
là-dessus je suis prêt à dos je pense et
pareil regardez de la même manière je
viens ici je vais sur Modifier juste en
bas et j'ai un anti-flou et l'anti flou
là c'est pareil il y a un truc qui est
vraiment badass regardez ça c'est la
photo d'origine ça c'est avec l'anti
flou alors on voit que c'est de l'algo
on peut venir le moduler si on veut que
ce soit un peu moins fort vous voyez
notamment sur les contours on le voit
ici là sur le contour du visage c'est là
où ça vient vraiment pousser le truc
mais je trouve ça tellement au parc
quand même de là et on arrive ici alors
vous me direz ça vient lisser ça
reconnait les traits il y a un algo
derrière mais j'ai l'impression de me
voir il y a quelques années alors que
c'était il y a peut-être 30 ans donc le
truc c'est un peu perturbant je ne vous
le cache pas allez je vous montre une
autre photo avec un ukulélé ça c'était
il y a quelques bonnes années aussi il y
a peut-être 15 ans je viens la modifier
elle est très floue pareil anti flou
alors là ça marche un peu moins bien
parce que je pense qu'il y a un peu de
mouvement au niveau de la photo mais on
part quand même de là pour arriver là
donc il y a quand même un lieu voyez si
vous le mettez comme ça ça va ça
fonctionne donc je trouve quand même
qu'il y a un côté qui est très efficace
et lorsque vous venez replonger dans
votre passé vous faites waouh qu'est-ce
qui se passe c'est chaud alors je vais
vous montrer autre chose maintenant
qu'on avait déjà avant et qui n'est pas
tout nouveau c'est la question de la
gomme magique alors la gomme magique
vous connaissez c'est toujours une photo
de moi là je remonte 22 ans 23 ans en
arrière je suis brun j'ai les cheveux
longs je fais du surf j'ai de ventre
plat c'est vraiment il y a longtemps et
là j'ai mon pote qui me regarde dans la
flotte qui se dit ouais je vais me
prendre gros sur la gueule alors je
m'appelais pas Gru à l'époque et bien
vous avez cette fameuse gomme magique
qui vous permet d'effacer des personnes
dans l'arrière-plan j'appuie ici
typiquement ça me le propose vous voyez
je vois mon pote qui est là je passe
bien sur lui et je veux que ça me le
supprime et là paf ça l'a repéré alors
ça me laisse un tout petit truc en bas
là qui est un peu bizarre dans la flotte
je continue à passer là et voilà je me
retrouve avec une photo je n'ai plus mon
pote qui m'embête donc ça effectivement
c'est la gomme magique alors on a autre
chose que la gomme magique si on veut
pas complètement le supprimer on peut
venir le camoufler je fais pareil hop là
vous voyez il est là je viens passer sur
lui un peu de tous les côtés voilà comme
ça comme ça jusque sur le haut du crâne
et là ça va me camoufler donc il est
toujours là vous voyez je peux venir
récupérer un peu le bas comme ça ça me
joue sur les teintes et là vous voyez
alors il est vert c'est très bizarre
mieux vaut utiliser la gomme magique je
fais effacer et de la même manière ça
vient de me le supprimer donc le truc
est complètement dingue et je trouve ça
une fois de plus extrêmement efficace
autre fonctionnalité de Google qui est
très cool c'est dans l'enregistreur par
exemple vous venez enregistrer je viens
enregistrer ici de l'audio on va
regarder c'est dans le cadre de ma vidéo
YouTube on va regarder si ça marche si
c'est intéressant oui non quoi comment
etc j'appuie là et là je vais avoir ma
transcription vous voyez on va regarder
dans le cas de ma vidéo YouTube on va
regarder si ça marche c'est intéressant
oui non quoi comment etc donc le truc
est très cool et en plus de ça ils ont
une fonctionnalité qui est vachement
intéressante surtout quelqu'un vous
envoie un message vocal vous pouvez pas
forcément venir l'écouter vous êtes en
réunion essayer ça et bien ça vous le
transcrit à vous aurez le texte donc si
vous avez un pote qui vous laisse un
long message vocal et bien vous aurez la
transcription ici directement ils sont
ça aussi une fois de plus très malin il
y a un autre mode qui est intéressant
c'est le mode Talkback regardez qui est
juste ici en fait il est destiné aux
personnes qui ont un déficit visuel et
il va venir lire ce qu'il y a sur
l'écran donc vous venez l'activer ici
voyez et par exemple voilà il vous parle
il vous dit tout par exemple j'appuie là
il va venir le texte
Talkback fournit des commentaires audio
je trouve ça extrêmement malin vous
voyez hop là
et là ils me disent qu'il y a vous voyez
par exemple j'ai le bouton j'appuie
dessus
voilà et ils me disent que c'est et si
je veux le valider il faut que j'appuie
deux fois vous voyez et je veux savoir
ce que c'est par exemple ça encore moins
lumineux
[Musique]
pour prononcer et si je veux valider il
faut que j'appuie deux fois pour aller
dedans donc je trouve ça vachement malin
parce qu'en fait c'est un truc qui
pourrait paraître tout con mais qu'on ne
trouvait pas avant hop là j'appuie deux
fois ok talk je rentre là alors moi je
désactive parce que je n'en ai pas
besoin j'arrête dans le bac voilà faut
bien que j'appuie deux fois et je trouve
ça extrêmement intelligent ça va même
guider les gens qui veulent faire des
selfies ça vous dira non mettez votre
smartphone comme ça faites si ça donc ça
une fois de plus c'est très très cool
autre usage qu'on avait déjà vu et que
fait ici cette puce Google sensor G2 et
bien c'est le realton vous savez c'est
pour garder la bonne carnation de peau
alors ici j'ai fait appel à mon copain
Brandon alors là hop la regarder on a
vraiment belle teinte de peau c'est
naturel c'est joli alors là il est très
éclairé mais si vous regardez bien par
ici on a vraiment des teintes qui sont
complètement préservés et qui marche
vachement bien deux jours comme de nuit
donc en fait le truc est vachement
intéressant ici avec cette puce et que
Google fait du Google et apporte des
fonctionnalités pour Google et en plus
de ça vous avez un truc qui est très
cool c'est que tous les trois mois vous
avez une mise à jour logiciel je verrai
même pas c'est complètement transparent
c'est ce qu'on appelle les futurs drop
tous les trois mois de nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui sont développées par
Google et qui arrivent directement sur
votre pixel alors ici vous avez une
expérience Android 13 vous avez 50 mise
à jour de sécurité donc vous êtes
tranquille et vous aurez plusieurs mises
à jour également d'Android dans le temps
jusqu'à ce que votre puce ne puisse plus
accepter donc ça aussi c'est très très
chouette donc en fait on voit qu'ici on
a de la performance en plus comme on est
sur modèle professionnel on a 12 Go
c'est la lpdr 5 et vous avez 128 256
soit 512 Go de stockage assez une exclu
512 pour le modèle Pro essaye de l'UFS
3.0 parfaitement bien puisque je vous
parle d'Android 13 et bien on a une base
d'Android 12 dessus avec notamment
matérial U qui permet de venir
complètement personnalisé son smartphone
vous pouvez choisir différents types de
couleurs on a de plus en plus de
combinaisons directement pour venir
moduler sur votre fond d'écran vous avez
vraiment tout ce qui ira bien vous allez
les couleurs de base vous allez pouvoir
se fond d'écran pour venir changer si
vous mettez un autre fond d'écran vous
aurez des couleurs qui vont être prises
de votre fond d'écran pour venir les
mettre ici bref c'est une expérience qui
est totalement personnalisable signée
Google et qui est très très cool alors
l'expérience matérielle au début on
l'avait déjà sur Android 12 on l'a sur
plein de smartphones Android mais c'est
vrai aussi que c'est un des très gros
points forts ici sur ce pixel 7 et Pixel
7 Pro les pixels sont réputés pour faire
de bonnes photos de jours comme de nuit
donc vous montrer tout de suite le
résultat photo du pixel pro alors
regardez on commence de nuit on est venu
se faire une petite balade la nuit avec
les copains vous allez les voir on va
dire coller dans quelques instants et
bisous à eux si regarde cette vidéo bon
dans l'ensemble c'est pas mal capteur
principal ça fonctionnera l'ultra
grand-angle on va oublier de toute façon
la nuit ultra grand-angle on va
globalement assez oublier on peut venir
zoomer un peu mais pas trop parce
qu'après ça va pas être terrible le truc
que je vais reprocher un peu tout au
long vous allez voir des photos avec ce
pixel 7 pro et bien c'est une petite
question de l'optique ou au niveau des
éclairages il a un peu de mal et vous
allez le voir à droite à gauche alors
bon ultra grand-angle on passe aussi on
peut venir zoomer un peu mais voilà là
il y a un petit problème d'expo est-ce
que c'est l'ampoule qui est trop forte
il a voulu compenser j'en sais rien en
tout cas c'est un peu fort ici ultra
grand-angle on oublie ok on zoom pas
terrible la regarder on trouve toujours
ce petit problème ici si on fait
abstraction de ce problème je trouve que
les photos sont très bien là au niveau
de la gestion de la lumière là-dessous
c'est bien j'ai bien le détail avec
rubrique là j'ai bien le bâtiment j'ai
bien les voitures et ça ça marche il y a
juste cette petite question d'optique
qui est un petit peu un petit peu un
petit peu moyenne et c'est dommage et
qu'on retrouve un petit peu
régulièrement l'art si vous regardez
cette photo avec Fred par exemple et
bien on a bien visage de Fred on voit
que l'algo a vraiment reconnu la zone un
peu plus d'ombre là il est un peu plus
clair on a bien son visage on va Brandon
au fond qui entrain de faire des photos
et donc ça fonctionne vous voyez il y a
un vrai ergot qui fonctionne bien
là-dessus donc ça c'est cool là c'est
pareil avec mon pote Brandon ça marche
très très bien comme ça hop on peut
venir se rapprocher légèrement si en
dessous et ok why not là ok ça marche
également ce que j'ai voulu venir
chercher ici c'est le bâtiment derrière
vous voyez qu'on arrive à revoir malgré
la Lumière que vous avez là donc c'est
pareil d'un point de vue purement
logiciel ça fonctionne bien en revanche
zoomer ça ressort davantage c'est très
très bien bon là c'était un petit peu
poussif au niveau du néon donc c'est un
peu compliqué mais c'était le néon et là
vous voyez on sort des choses qui sont
pas mal attention toujours à ses
éclairages là pour vraiment venir
maîtriser vos photos mais vous le verrez
de toute façon sur votre aperçu donc bon
il y aura pas normalement de mauvaise
surprise et sinon dans l'ensemble j'aime
bien les photos nues je trouve ça très
joli au niveau des teintes de peau aussi
quel que soit votre carnation est bien
fonctionne et très bien et ça c'est un
truc aussi important qu'un mis en avant
Google c'est le realton pour que quel
que soit votre carnation vous ayez un
résultat à la mesure là ici pas de souci
vous voyez ça a bien fonctionné et dans
l'ensemble je vous le dis une fois de
plus j'aime bien le rendu photo ici même
là en venant zoomer davantage bon on va
un peu éviter la nuit sans quoi on va
récupérer quand même vachement de bruit
ici même problème avec cet éclairage là
sinon si on fait abstraction de ça le
reste de la photo est très cool là c'est
pareil on se retrouve à Bastille ok
caméra de selfie la nuit et leur
globalement on va venir éviter parce que
c'est pas très ouf en terme de qualité
que vous l'ayez comme ça regardez au
niveau des pots c'est bruité c'est
vraiment pas ouf et on a aussi une
fonction
ultra grand-angle c'est la même optique
mais on vient élargir légèrement et ça
fonctionne également c'est plutôt
convenable voilà caméra de selfie vous
en montrer une autre on va oublier un
très clairement ici petite photo de nuit
bon ok on vient maintenant faire un tour
le jour alors le jour je suis venu
shooter ici parce que vous voyez on a le
soleil qui est caché derrière le
bâtiment mais le ciel on le voit bien on
voit bien le bâtiment ici avec un peu
plus de soleil ici un peu moins de
soleil ça fonctionne sur l'ultra grand
temps que ça fonctionne très bien aussi
également de jour on peut venir zoomer x
2 x 5 et vous allez voir c'est quoi on
peut monter x 10 on peut monter x 20 on
peut monter jusqu'à x 30 là c'est pareil
ça fonctionne bien grand-angle ultra
grand temps ok donc là on est sur le
grand angle l'ultra grand-angle lorsque
je vois ici c'est que vous voyez le fond
là c'est légèrement un peu plus cramé
mais c'est très loin et c'est un point
de détail donc c'est pas très très
déconnant on vient zoomer x 2 x 5 là on
est au x 10 et là on est au x 30 alors
le X 30 vous allez voir que globalement
le truc qui est un petit peu touché un
peu compliqué et bien c'est que on
ressort pas grand chose mais par contre
il y a un truc qui est très intéressant
c'est que le X 30 il est extrêmement
stabilisé dès la stabilité lorsque je
zoomer x 2 x 5 alors avec moi qu'un
tremblement essentiel c'est la merde en
plus si je monte en X 10 ça bouge pas ça
va être vachement et là si je vais en X
30 pareil c'est extrêmement stable hop
là je viens ajouter juste ça tac ça
marche donc c'est très très stable
regardez là c'est pareil on se rapproche
de la plage des Vosges la place des
Vosges pas la plage la place de la place
des Vosges ça fonctionne bien quand on
ultra grand-angle on peut venir zoomer
on se rapproche ok là je suis venu
chercher un peu le contre-jour avec le
soleil juste là ça me ressort bien la
façade ok bon pas de mauvaise surprise
là-dessus ici en venant zoomer ça
fonctionne également alors forcément
quand vous avez le soleil dans le dos et
que ça éclaire et bien c'est très très
beau et ça marche très très bien lorsque
j'avais reproché un peu l'année dernière
c'est que je trouvais que c'était un peu
trop saturé un peu trop sur saturé et là
je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
naturel que ce que j'avais que le pixel
si pro donc ça me convainc beaucoup
mieux on peut venir zoomer également et
voyez jusqu'en x 30 là contre jour
effectivement avec vous voyez mes troncs
qui sont à contre-jour avec mon soleil
en pleine tronche et bien je vois bien
ma façade j'ai bien mes feuilles j'ai
bien aussi mes zones d'ombres ici avec
l'appel j'ai bien je vois c'est
intéressant le tronc de l'arbre avec des
détails qui apparaissent à droite et à
gauche donc ça c'est cool ça marche bien
ultra grand-angle également on peut
venir zoomer moi venir éviter là c'est
pareil toujours sur des questions de
contre-jour c'est là où on voit
effectivement ce qui est capable de
sortir le smartphone d'un point de vue
purement algorithmique et on voit que ça
fonctionne très bien alors là je suis
venu chercher de la macro vous savez la
macro et moi sur les smartphones en
règle générale on n'est pas trop pote
c'est souvent des capteurs de mégapixels
et la qualité souvent n'est pas au
rendez-vous et là j'étais interloqué pas
bleu fait mais interloqué ça marche bien
parce que regardez on voit bien tout ce
petit détail on voit bien toutes les
petites toiles d'araignées là ça marche
très très bien une feuille alors bon on
voit bien ce petit détail avec la
matière un petit peu de petit peu de
flotte je sais pas c'est une espèce de
la pression de l'arbre j'en sais rien
voyez hop je trouve ça quand même pas
mal fichu alors on peut venir zoomer
vous allez voir la particularité en X 2
et jusqu'en x 5 on oublie parce que sur
la macro la X5 c'est dégueulasse voyez
quelques clichés et je trouve ça quand
même vachement bien en mode macro votre
smartphone la position soit désactivez
la macro en appuyant là donc là il y a
pas de macro soit vous appuyez là et
vous êtes sur la macro et en macro
pouvez venir me zoomer donc lorsque j'ai
hop là à peu près fait mon point voyez
je peux venir zoomer comme ça pour
rentrer un peu plus alors après le choix
5 on évite parce que c'est pas terrible
mais jusqu'au x 2 on peut réussir à
sortir des choses et enfin même en x 0,5
bon là je vois globalement pas l'intérêt
du tout enfin FX2 macros why not caméra
de selfie de plein jour alors là j'ai
essayé de différents trucs où j'ai un
peu de soleil un peu d'ombre à
contre-jour et compagnie vous allez voir
c'est pareil c'est pas ouf il y a un
côté légèrement brute pas très précis
lorsqu'on a des zones d'ombre et qui a
du soleil derrière forcément il vient
compenser d'un point de vue
algorithmique et on voit un peu la
faiblesse ici là vous voyez j'ai un peu
plus de soleil le détail ça sera
beaucoup plus joli ici que ça le sera
moins au niveau de mon front après oui
les impuretés de ma peau c'est pas
terrible comme ça vous savez tout
néanmoins il s'en sort vous contre-jour
j'ai quand même le soleil qui est juste
là et il me ressort bien le visage et je
trouve ça pas mal fichu un peu moins
côté trop poussif au niveau de l'algo
par rapport à ce que j'avais vu l'année
dernière sur le pixel 6 pro bon là j'ai
vraiment cherché un peu la merde donc
bon mais voyez lorsque vous lui mettez
une vraie belle source de lumière il
s'en sort bien après je vais rien vous
apprendre ici on fait de la photo il
faut de la lumière de toute façon là ce
que je viens chercher c'est les scènes
un petit peu plus complexe pour avoir la
démonstration de l'algorithme et voir ce
que ça peut ressortir le poussin un peu
dans sa tranchement dans l'idée
déconnait pas mettez-vous au soleil
lorsque vous en avez et lorsque vous
avez pas de soleil vous allez voir ça
fonctionnera bien et il sortira très
très bien il travaillera très très bien
bon là c'est pareil 8 jours millions ça
marche sur le côté grand angle et sur le
côté un peu ultra grand temps que c'est
le même optique pour autant sur votre
caméra de selfie et ça fonctionne il y a
mode intéressant sur le pixel 7 pro
c'est le mode cinématique ça va venir
mettre un flou en arrière-plan ça c'est
très cool parce que ça marche avec deux
liens c'est pas du tout quelque chose de
complètement naturel si c'est pas une
question optique mais pour autant ça
marche bien ça détour bien le sol
inconvénient ici c'est qu'on pourra
filmer au maximum en Full HD on pourra
pas avoir de quelqu'un donc si vous
voulez faire de la 4K et si vous voulez
arrière-plan peut-être faudra-t-il
attendre la puce Google tensor G3 en
tout cas là j'ai deux pour l'instant
elle le fait en Full HD elle le fait
plutôt bien elle détour plutôt bien
c'est vraiment pratique et ça marche
bien donc ça c'est chouette ce Google
pixel 7 Pro marche très bien et ce qui
est chouette surtout c'est que vous avez
plein de possibilités l'interface est
très complète on peut venir faire plein
de choses en vidéo je trouve ça
vachement bien regardé je vous montre
l'interface il y a un gros point fort
ici au niveau de ce smartphone c'est
toute l'interface que vous allez avoir
d'un point de vue logiciel parce qu'elle
est très claire elle est très complète
je vous montre ne serait-ce qu'au niveau
de la vidéo par exemple alors vous
choisissez en haut votre résolution ici
je suis en 4K 60 assez pratique on peut
se mettre en HDR si on le souhaite bon
clairement ici c'est pas ça que je le
mets je vais rester comme ça je vais
avoir effectivement un mode accéléré je
vais avoir un mode ralenti vous voyez
que vous allez avoir juste ici et là
j'ai un ma stabilisation différents
niveaux de stabilisation tu vas voir une
stabilisation un peu standard et vous le
marque pour des mouvements légers par
défaut une stabilisation plan fixe donc
là je vais être en X 2 ou en X 5 ici en
mouvement donc lorsque je vais me bouger
lorsque je vais bouger je vais me
déplacer j'aurais une c'est bien sûr un
peu plus forte et puis panoramique
cinématique donc j'ai différent niveau
de stabilisation ici je trouve ça
vraiment très très cool surtout pour moi
c'est un tremblement essentiel croyez
moi c'est très important d'avoir une
bonne stabilisation on va ensuite être
dans la partie photo qui est aussi très
clair avec le 1 le 2 voyez vous appuyez
vous laissez appuyer vous pouvez monter
alors on sent sous le doigt quand on
arrive au x 30 ou qu'on fasse le X 10 on
sent un petit claque donc ça c'est aussi
pratique c'est plutôt pas mal fichu
lorsque je viens me rapprocher là vous
voyez ça met la petite icône ça veut
dire que je suis en macro j'ai calculé
ici pour désactiver la macro et appuyer
pour venir l'activer vous voyez je
change de caméra ça switch donc ça aussi
c'est assez malin le mode portrait bon
on connaît qui est très très pratique
mouvement pose longue pose longue avec
mouvement la vision de nuit aussi qui
est très très cool et puis vous avez le
mode cinématique ici qui est uniquement
et je vous le disais en Full HD et puis
après vous avez quelques petits modes en
plus ici le mode Panorama le photosphère
et le modelance voilà c'est simple c'est
clair c'est épuré et c'est très
compréhensible moi le smartphone je
trouve cool alors après le seul truc
c'est que je vais le trouver des fois un
petit peu large vous voyez on est sur le
modèle Pro c'est un grand écran c'est
une grande diagonale il faut faire
extrêmement attention en venant
l'utiliser à une main une fois de plus
des protéger avec une coque de
protection mais l'objet je trouve joli
je trouve pratique il y a plein de
jolies fonctionnalités donc si vous
aimez ce que propose Google si vous
aimez l'expérience Google et que vous
avez tous vos comptes Google c'est
probablement le smartphone qu'il vous
faut si maintenant vous n'aimez pas
Google je pense que vous n'irez pas
acheter ce smartphone et si vous
préférez
[ __ ] et si vous préférez l'expérience
iOS et bien c'est pas non plus ce
smartphone qu'il vous faudra si
maintenant par contre vous voulez aller
plus loin et bien dans l'écosystème
Google il y a des écouteurs et il y a
aussi une montre qui est ici et il y a
une tablette qui arrivera l'année
prochaine donc on en parlera également
l'année prochaine on part d'ailleurs
probablement prochainement de
l'écosystème Google parce que il y a
plein de jolis produits pour la maison
donc c'est un smartphone qui est cool
SIM ici
IP68 NFC pour le paiement des
matérialisé Google paye bien évidemment
Google cast et du wifi 6e et tout ça au
tarif de 899 € sur les modèles pro donc
s'il vous intéresse bien évidemment je
vous mets un lien juste en bas dans la
description est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
se parle très prochainement des pixels
cette est-ce que ça vous intéresse qu'on
se fasse un focus sur les pixel 7 dites
le moi dans les commentaires et puis
bien évidemment on se parle très bientôt
de la pixel watch moi c'est un
smartphone que je trouve cool je le
trouve bien il y a de très jolis
évolutions par rapport à ce qu'on avait
l'année dernière la grosse évolution
majeure ça va surtout être cette
nouvelle puce googleensor G2 qui va
porter plus de performances plus de
capacité de calcul dédié réellement à
Google donc ça c'est chouette comment
vous le trouvez ce smartphone sur la
partie photos sur la partie écran sur le
côté multimédia dites-moi tout ça juste
en bas dans les commentaires et puis
surtout c'est un smartphone qui est un
peu différent c'est un smartphone qui
est un peu plus atypique par rapport à
ce qu'on a l'habitude de trouver sur
Android on est toujours soit du côté de
chez Qualcom soit du côté de chez
médiathèque il y a cette puce qui est
une nouvelle alternative qui est
intéressante alors il y avait
effectivement Huawei mais comme on les
retrouve aujourd'hui un petit peu moins
sur le marché je les mets un peu plus
entre parenthèses mais voilà je trouve
ça chouette je trouve ça intéressant
est-ce que ça pourrait vous tenter
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu les pixel 6
pixel 6 pro pixel 6a peut-être dites-moi
ce que vous en pensez puis est-ce que
vous pourriez craquer sur ce modèle
professionnel du pixel 7 marquez moi ça
en bas dans les commentaires on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer bien
évidemment à part les TEC à parler de
montre de montre connectée avec la pixel
watch ça c'est cool je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]